Have you heard what rap sounded like in the 1940s?
♪ Yes just come on Brothers if you want to
hear a story about that Preacher and the Bear.
Gather round boys I don't want you to miss none
of this here story because it goes like this. ♪
That's a recording from 1945, called Preacher and
the Bear from the gospel group The Jubalaires.
And the cadence and flow sounds incredibly
similar to this hit song from 1979...
Rapper's Delight by the Sugar Hill Gang was the
first rap single to reach the top 40 charts.
When Rapper's Delight was released hip hop
and its four main elements: DJing, graffiti,
b-boying and emceeing or rapping had long
already been established in New York City.
But for the rest of the world hearing Rappers
Delight for the first time, rapping was new.
Or was it? Because Preacher and the Bear by the
Jubalaires was recorded over 30 years earlier!